the new season of Game of Thrones is
fast approaching but in order to look at
where they might be heading we have to
go back back to the cover of the first
book we have an image of a sword but
what can we learn from it answers are
never easy with George Armand
he's always asking us to look under the
surface let's enhance there's someone's
reflection in the sword it appears to be
one of the lesser known characters
crispy beers interesting
what's this in the reflection of his eye
I thought said it's a 1950s recording of
Elvis Presley doing the hound dog hound
he's telling us the hound wears a dog
helmet well we already knew that let's
go deeper okay so we set a board of
Catan for us I'm quite good at this
what cards do we have two wood and two
for Rick I have enough to build two
years loads that puts me in front to
take the longest road car what's this
the longest toad Todd you'll find my
secrets in the mouth of the toe sure
come on in
let's go inside this toads mouth but
that would be too easy wouldn't it so
I'm gonna go up his anus right by my
calculations it should take us three
weeks to reach the frogs mouth if we
take this route I'm not really sure
where we are lord it's a sort of mucky
cabin dripping with feces we have enough
rations for two days so we should be
able to live off the land or frogs
so to speak in case we get lost I have
my mate base to guide us through now the
video feed isn't great but we are up a
frog's anus so bear with me let's take
stock of our supplies we've got a paper
clip there's some sunflower seeds a
couple of empty batteries and an
excellent
so what use is all this I suppose we
could
what's inscribed on the seed it's some
sort of rune it's the 2014 Olympics logo
oh it's Bart Simpson and Sideshow Bob
go away Jim what was I doing stop
touching me what was that
[Music]
learn